قال مسؤولون استخباراتيون أتراك رفيعو المستوى
إنهم اعتقلوا
شقيقة أبو بكر البغدادي النحاسية ،
كما تم القبض على هوارد مع
زوجة ابنها وخمسة
أطفال كما
يقول الأتراك ، لكنهم رفضوا تحديد موعد هذه
الاعتقالات.  تم التقاطهم ، ونشروا
صورًا لأخت البغدادي وبالفعل
لوثائق الهوية التي
كانوا يحملونها معهم
وقت إلقاء القبض عليهم في مدينة اعزاز ، كما
ورد في حاوية سكنية الآن ،
وهي نوع من أنواع الإقامة التي يستخدمها
اللاجئون في كثير من الأحيان من  في أماكن أخرى في
سوريا ، لا سيما حلب ، ولكن مع
ذلك كان هذا أيضًا على طريق تهريب شهير
قريب جدًا من الحدود التركية
في منطقة كان للأتراك فيها
وجود عسكري الآن لبعض الوقت
قالوا إنها تمثل
كنزًا محتملاً من المعلومات الاستخبارية
و  هذا سيكون صحيحًا ، ما يمكن أن تقوله
لهم سيساعدهم في تجميع
المزيد من النسيج أو أحجية الصور
المقطوعة التي أدت سريعًا إلى  قتل
البغدادي على يد الكوماندوز الأمريكيين وضربتَين متتاليتين
ضد قادة آخرين
داخل ما يسمى بالدولة الإسلامية ، لكن
من المحتمل أن تكون
قد خضعت للمراقبة لبعض الوقت
لأنها كانت خلال تلك الفترة في
كثير من الأحيان بمجرد أن يحدد أحد الأصول من هذا
النوع ذلك.
يمكن مراقبتهم وتحديد الشبكة الأوسع
وقد يكون ذلك جزءًا مما أدى
إلى تحديد
الموقع الذي قُتل فيه البغدادي في نهاية المطاف
أيضًا في شمال سوريا مثلها وليس
في المنطقة التي يُطلق عليها
عادة الدولة الإسلامية.  كان له نفوذ ولكن من الواضح أنه
منطقة شعر فيها أفراد عائلته
بالأمان وسيكون السؤال الآن
خاصًا للمسؤولين الأتراك
إلى أي مدى كانت لديهم اتصالات
عبر الحدود داخل الأراضي التركية
نفسها
Sam Kiley CNN Abu Dhabi